[Music]
I did that way too long yeah
here are some BuzzFeed lists I saw
recently check this out
16 guys we wish weren't wearing v-neck
t-shirts oh yeah
disgusting look at this one 11 wanted
criminals meeting Sean Penn for Froyo no
yeah this one nine therapists who are
secretly sexting I've always had a hunch
yeah
26 people who thought the Apple watch
was gonna change their lives but still
feel empty inside
why is she naked in front of a window I
don't get that I love that Louis ones
seven former attack drones that
successfully transitioned into the
private sector that is nice yeah 14
people who don't know a spider crawls on
their face every night yeah no one liked
that no they don't
mmm-hmm 18 photos of US presidents in
the bathtub hello he seems very calm no
I would have I would have thought he'd
be hairier no no not at all
that's the v-neck guy Hey look at this
31 geometry teachers eating alone at
Baja Fresh oh boy I get that guy he's is
it all went wrong for him 12 Hitler's
that look like cats now that's just
stupid
ridiculous Oh - this time 46 times the
patch Adams nose failed to get laughs
crowd bummed out again we're here to bum
people out Hey look at this 14
caterpillars that never turn into
butterflies but instead went to work at
their dad's auto body shop
six things you can learn from his custom
bicycle seat oh boy bander and finally
one that won't top it 14 amazing
before-and-after photos of guys who lost
a hundred pounds but then came back 97
pound
[Applause]
you